we turn to Japan the country that gave
us Pokemon and oh my god it's a
Jigglypuff I've never seen one of these
in the world before okay stay calm stay
calm quick take out a pokeball and
slowly and carefully promise you ready
and anyway where was I oh that's right
Japan there is something amazing
happening over there right now as we've
discussed before Japan is home to
thousands of mascots for everything from
museums to prisons to entire towns and
cities you may remember we loved that
idea so much that we actually made our
own unofficial mascots for various US
government agencies well it turns out
we're not the only ones who've decided
to make some less than official mascots
a rogue mascot is causing a lot of
controversy in one japanese Sumeet sheet
on the unsanctioned otter mascot that is
gaining popularity on social media
thanks to its edgy personality video of
cheatin swinging a weed eater and you
can see him there dancing on a pole oh
my goodness yes your eyes are not
deceiving you that is video of a
Japanese mascot on a stripper pole
presumably at a strip club called there
are way more people are into this sort
of thing than you think but it is my
absolute honor tonight to introduce you
to cheat on and you're gonna be glad
that I did I know that he may look like
half a Vienna finger that took too much
ecstasy in the 90s but chi-town is in
his own words a zero year old fairy baby
who plays around super actively every
day as you can tell she tan is a giant
otter wearing a turtle as a hat which is
incidentally already my favorite
sentence of all time right next to
welcome to the John Oliver koala
chlamydia wart but the story the story
though of what's going on with Chi Thanh
is a little complicated but but in a
nutshell there's a city in Japan called
Sasaki su sakis official mascot is
Shinjo kun a magnificent giant otter
wearing a ramen dish for a hat
excellent until recently the city also
had a honorary tourism ambassador an
actual otter named Chetan as it happens
cheat on the actual otter has a mascot
otter and that is what Chetan is the
point is there are three otters two of
which are named Chetan and the mascot
Chetan was never formally affiliated
with the city of Sioux sake
it's that simple and the unofficial
mascot Chetan has been producing some
bizarre videos not just the stripper
pole one but also this one where cheatin
flips a car with its bare paws now
Sasaki reportedly received over a
hundred calls from around Japan
complaining about GTRs behavior and
earlier this year the city is empty to
distance themselves from it by declining
to renew the real Chetan as its tourism
ambassador basically the city cut ties
with the real otter because of the
things the fake otter did which is a
real shame because cheatin has been a
lot of fun it's Twitter account is full
of crazy like this
[Music]
now you might be wanting to ask how does
an umbrella wielding coked-up otter
being assaulted in a windowless room
encourage tourism to the small Japanese
port city of Sasaki well I'm on TV and
I'm talking about the small Japanese
port city of Sasaki so that should
answer your stupid question the
point is every two time video is a work
of art take this one for example titled
with my friends it's understandable to
have a lot of questions after watching
that like what am I watching
who's the karate cat and why's cheat
aren't angry with that inflatable Pole
but you'll notice that a my board is not
one of the questions you're asking there
violence is actually something of a
theme with Chetan here's another video
that starts charming and then has a bit
of a turn
[Music]
it is a testament to the utter
brilliance of that video that I've
watched it literally dozens of times and
not once have I given a moment's thought
to whether or not that person was okay
honestly it doesn't matter cuz even if
they weren't it was completely worth it
as good as these videos are cheat on is
somehow even better at Twitter with a
virtuosic deployment of memes just look
at this
hello burp hello Pulitzer Prize for
poetry
here's another magnificent example don't
ever talk to my son or my son son or my
son son son or my son son son son ever
again just try saying that without
laughing it's physiologically impossible
asking me to pick a favorite cheat on
tweet is like asking me to pick a
favorite son or son son or sunset the
point is it'll be difficult but I would
probably have to say this one in which
cheatin standing next to a small
kangaroo asks is this a pigeon I mean
come on
clearly the question is rhetorical
Chetan is famously excellent at
recognizing burbs when's the last time
Twitter made you happy when's the last
time anything made you happy
the problem is even I will admit the
cheeto has occasionally gone a bit too
far like with this video titled Chetan
is going to visit your house
I accept even the most generous
interpretation of that is that she's hot
he's gonna come to your house and beat
you to death with a baseball bat
and I do get why a city might not want
that message delivered by a
self-appointed unofficial mascot but I
am sorry for Sue sake that he's gone and
I'd also like you to spare a thought for
their official mascot
Shinjo Koon who is also as we've
established excellent not as splashy as
cheat on shore but still wears a noodle
bowl for a hat and that's not nothing is
it Shinjuku was clearly overshadowed by
an unhinged psychotic unsanctioned often
well I'm sure that there's an element of
relief there fishing Joe there's
also gonna be a massive cheat on shaped
hole in its life now the two mascots
were together a lot and I have to say
whenever you see Shinjo alone now
the obvious sadness there is absolutely
heartbreaking but what I will say here
is it's clear that Shinjuku needs a new
friend this time one that won't
disappear or threaten the citizens of
zoo sake with a baseball bat luckily as
we now know anyone can make an
unofficial mascot for a city in Japan
and if you don't already know where this
is heading you clearly never watch this
show before because of course we
made our own mascot of course we did
please meet
it's a forty one-year-old nearsighted
English fairy baby now ordinarily when
there's a new mascot on this show I get
up from this desk and walk over there to
introduce you to him in person the bad
news is I can't actually introduce you
to cheat John in person tonight the good
news is the reason I can't do that is
because these are already in Japan it's
true here he is having the time of his
life in Tokyo okay I get it John you
just created a mascot to go to Japan and
with people but no you don't
actually get it you don't get it at all
we may cheat John with the sole
intention that he locates and comfort
shinji-kun and fill the hole that cheat
on left in his heart and for a sense of
whether he was able to do that you
should probably take a look at this
after a long flight Chi John arrived in
Tokyo
he'd never seen anything like it because
he just got classes the day before
tomorrow he'd visit suzaki but tonight
belong to Tokyo
[Music]
violently hungover Chi John got up the
next morning and as he looked through
the clouds towards Sasaki he remembered
the reason he was here Shinjo gone he
was 100% sure they were meant to be
together and 40% sure he was looking at
Sasaki
all the way to the train station Qi
John's heart pounded each step was a
step closer to his destiny
after a while he got tired of taking
steps and took a rickshaw each step of
his rickshaw driver was a step closer to
his destiny at last
Sasaki Shinjuku was everywhere on the
stairs of the sidewalk of walls and in
the streets on his way
she John introduced himself to all the
local fish this is the path that falls
at Shinjuku ng's feet this is the breeze
that cool Shinjuku n--'s face this is
the Sun that warms the noodles that
shinji-kun wears as a hat and knowing
this filled t-jon with joy
the final steps to his destiny were
uphill aren't they always
finally Chi John saw Shin joke on his
new best friend ginger Cole didn't know
if he was ready for a new best friend he
had had a best friend cheat on and it
had been a living nightmare but
she John seemed different less upper
body strength for one thing at the local
arcade they used sticks to whack moans
not each other though they share an
Appetite for Destruction destroying
something together is an act of creation
Shinjo could made she John happy and she
John wanted Shinjo Kunta have a Shinjuku
Shinjuku could be happy to her but she
John couldn't get into a Kona shinji-kun
and this made them sad now sadness was
another thing they shared she John tried
to cheer shinji-kun up he put on ginger
cones thinking cap suddenly he knew just
what to do introduce themselves to some
local fish ginger couldn't torch to John
how to take one stick and make two
sticks it was the best day of their
lives without the sadness of the claw
machine shinjuku never would have felt
this joy and if his old best friend
hadn't left his new best friend never
would have come
that's too much soy sauce ginger
said no replied she John it's not enough
fish Shin drakul had fouled his new best
friend a little chaos fulfills the
spirit and prepares us for all the claw
machines ahead
they saw their path and felt their
breeze and saw their son where is our
son going Chi John asked do not worry
said Shinjo kun will have our son back
tomorrow and our Sun Sun and our Sun Sun
Sun and our Sun Sun Sun
one of us thought this was where I shall
was going tonight and yet here we are
now G John and this is true is still in
Japan the city of Sasaki have now
officially taken ownership of him so if
you ever want to see Qi John in the
flesh or in the fur you will simply have
to go there